Tohji and Kensuke...
Everybody left to find somewhere else
to live after losing their homes here.
There's nobody... There's nobody
here that I can call a friend now.
Nobody.
I can't even go see Ayanami.
I don't have the courage.
I don't know how I should treat her.
Asuka, Ms. Misato, Mom... What should I...
What should I do?
Aren't songs great?
Songs enrich the heart.
They're the crowning achievement
of Lilin culture.
Don't you think so...
Shinji Ikari?
-You know my name?
-Everybody knows you.
No offense, but I think you should
be more aware of your importance.
I should?
Um, who are you?
I'm Kaworu. Kaworu Nagisa.
Like you, I'm a child whose path has
been set out. I'm the Fifth Children.
You're the Fifth Children, uh... Nagisa?
Call me Kaworu, Ikari.
Um, call me Shinji, then.